hi buddy aaron sampson here with carolyn
Pettit hey who has just come back from
seeing destiny competitive multiplayer
as opposed to a cooperative multiplayer
right and you were also in the alpha
yeah I got to spend a little time in the
Alpha so I've kind of seen both
components of the game at this point i
guess if people want a sense of what the
core gameplay in destiny is like I think
Borderlands thinking of it as a
variation on borderlands is kind of a
good place to start right because you
have classes you unlock powers and you
level up and there's loot and you know
gear and stuff that you find in the
world having said that of course the
tone of the game is very very different
from the borderlands games it's a it's a
very kind of serious somber sci fi game
that Bungie you know who did all this
work creating galore for the Halo series
is obviously pouring an awful lot of
energy into creating a rich lure for
destiny as well you know how good at
that aspects that the game is going to
be it's hard to tell with these little
bits and pieces but as far as the
gameplay itself so when you're playing
you know single player or cooperatively
with friends you're in the world with
other players right so you might see
other players in the environment and
they're there at least the one
environment that's available in the
Alpha is this really kind of expansive
environment you can zip around it on
this vehicle that's like a speeder bike
which is kind of a lot of fun and it's
not exactly like an open-world game like
an MMO right yeah you have it you have a
hub right and you launch your like
strike missions yeah their explorations
from that exactly if people are
envisioning this as one interconnected
universe it's not that they are large
but separate zones that you go to to do
missions and things so the one area is
like in old Russia it's called and and
as you're in the world with other
players these public events happen so
this might be something like a giant
powerful spider tank gets kind of
dropped into the environment and you and
any other players in the environment can
work together to kind of take these
things down to accomplish the
tasks and you're rewarded for
participating in these you get loot and
experience points or if you just want to
go about and you're out your own
business and do your own thing you can
totally safely ignore those public
events and just continue doing whatever
you're doing now having mentioned
Borderlands yeah the player counts on
some of the strike missions I think are
very similar to a border lands match so
there are in destiny there are these
missions called strikes which are
designed I think specifically for three
players like three is the maximum on
those there will also be endgame raids
which are for six players but they
haven't I have not seen any of that they
haven't really shown that yet they just
kind of tease the concept when I went to
see the game at bungie recently but yes
so so strike teams teams of three taking
on these structured kind of story
missions where you go through you know
and it builds up and there's a boss
fight at the end and and these are the
kind of like you might do runs in a game
like Diablo or an MMO repeatedly to get
certain gear I think these raids are
designed to be similar where you might
just kind of do them over and over again
until you get that particular loot drop
that you're looking for so in terms of
the feel of destiny no halo is it ah I
mean I'd say that it's it's not unlike
halo entirely it has a similar kind of
Bungie float eNOS to it I would say but
of course the class powers do set it
apart a little bit I enjoyed so during
today's multi competitive multiplayer
session I enjoyed being the Warlock
there so each class has supers that they
can do which charge up over time they're
on a cooldown timer and and they are
these kind of devastating attacks so
catching other players off guard with
that was a lot of fun and and also in
the multiplayer match that I played
today here at e3 on the on this moon
base map there were vehicles which which
kind of changed things up a bit there
was one that was sort of like like the
speeder bikes but heftier and armed and
I was able to kind of zap other players
with that
you know players who are on foot which
which was just a lot of fun well thanks
so much Galen 47 by and talking about
destiny sure for more coverage of e3
including destiny stay tuned to gamespot
com